[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin schönen guten Abend zusammen
die besten Bilder vom Super Bowl später
bei dir Sven schönen guten Abend hier
sind unsere Themen an diesem Montag
ein kniffliges Wahlergebnis in Berlin
will die SPD trotz Verlusten weiter
regieren dann stünde die klare
Wahlsiegerin CDU mit leeren Händen da
ein nicht endender Albtraum im
Erdbebengebiet steigt die Zahl der Opfer
auf über 37.000 und mehrere Millionen
Menschen sind obdachlos
ein mehr in blau-weiß in Massen gehen
Israelis auf die Straße weil sie durch
die Reformpläne der Ultra rechten
Regierung ihre Demokratie in Gefahr
sehen
[Musik]
die CDU fährt bei der Berlin-Wahl auf
der Siegerstraße aber möglicherweise
gleichzeitig in eine Sackgasse die
abgestrafte Koalition aus SPD Grünen und
Linken signalisiert nämlich weitermachen
zu wollen und hätte auch eine Mehrheit
dass die FDP aus dem Abgeordnetenhaus
flog macht die Arbeit in der Ampel auf
Bundesebene auch nicht leichter schauen
wir noch mal auf die Zahlen nach dem
vorläufigen amtlichen Endergebnis kommt
die CDU auf 28,2 Prozent SPD und Grüne
auf jeweils 18,4 die SPD mit einem
hauchdünnen Vorsprung von nur 105
stimmen die Linke
12,2%, die AFD 9,1 die FDP verpasst mit
4,6% den Wiedereinzug ins
Abgeordnetenhaus Dritter Buchholz
berichtet
einen solchen Applaus haben sie lange
nicht gehört im Konrad-Adenauer-Haus
während des Wahlkampf stand märz in der
Kritik auch wegen seiner Aussage zu
kleinen Paschas nun sieht er sich als
bestätigte an klar sei auch wer nun in
Berlin regieren müsse jedenfalls nicht
Rot-Grün rot der jetzige Senat mag noch
über eine rechnerische Mehrheit im
Abgeordnetenhaus verfügen politisch hat
er die Mehrheit gestern verspielt die
Mehrheit will den Wechsel
geknickt dagegen die SPD der regierende
Franziska Giffey ohne am sponos eine
Wahl Schlappe für gleich zwei Ampel
Partner die SPD und die FDP die
Parteivorsitzende versucht
Schadensbegrenzung wir arbeiten in der
Ampel in sehr gutem Einvernehmen
zusammen da wo wir unterschiedlicher
Ansicht sind da setzen wir uns zusammen
und besprechen die Sachen ständig nach
Profil Profil zu rufen wird nicht helfen
sondern es geht vor allem um die
verantwortungsvolle zusammen
Zusammenarbeit für das Wohl des Landes
der dritte Platz für die Grünen nur 100
und fünf Stimmen hinter der SPD
eigentlich wollten sie die
Bürgermeisterin Stellen dennoch wir
sehen dass wir unser bisher bestes
Ergebnis in Berlin stabilisieren konnten
und so natürlich auch mit einem starken
Fundament als Grüne in dieses Jahr 2023
starten die Linken freuen sich endlich
mal wieder über ein gutes Wahlergebnis
ob sie aber weiter regieren fraglich ein
Bündnis mit der AFD schließen alle aus
man freue sich auf eine starke
Oppositionsrolle und die FDP hat noch
nicht einmal die in Berlin raus aus dem
Abgeordnetenhaus als Grund dafür sieht
Lindner auch eine Doppelrolle mit der
Ampel im Bund regieren und im Land
Opposition sein das hätte nicht
funktioniert
auf den letzten Metern haben wir hier
taktisch an Union verloren und konnten
unsere Anhängerinnen und Anhänger nicht
mobilisieren die dann sich für die
Nichtwahl entschieden haben als
Konsequenz schließt der allerdings
Hektik oder gar Krawall aus doch das
Bittere Ergebnis der FDP könnte für die
Ampel durchaus eine Bürde werden
es gibt viele Fragezeichen nach der Wahl
chakr Unterleib energy in Berlin was
bedeutet das Berliner Wahlergebnis für
die Ampel
so zuhört dann bedeutet das
wahrscheinlich mehr Konfrontation
zwischen den Koalitionspartnern und das
eben mit Ansage denn der FDP-Chef hat ja
deutlich gemacht dass er eine einen der
Gründe für die Wahl Schlappe in Berlin
darin sieht dass eben die FDP in dem
beim mit regieren hier in Berlin auf
Bundesebene nicht genug Abgrenzung
schafft von den anderen Parteien von SPD
und Grünen und das will er wohl ändern
er hat davon inhaltlichen Konsequenzen
gesprochen zum Beispiel in den Bereichen
Verkehr Migration und Wirtschaft und da
hat es ja bisher schon an verschiedenen
Stellen geknirscht zwischen den
Koalitionspartnern gerade in diesen
Bereichen da wird also mehr
Reibungspunkte geben er hat heute auch
noch einmal gesagt wir müssen verhindern
dass das Land nach links geführt wird
damit kann er eigentlich nur seine
eigenen Koalitionspartner meinen der
beschreibt damit eben eine ähm Rolle als
Korrektiv für die FDP innerhalb der
Ampel und das wird die Zusammenarbeit
sicherlich nicht erleichtern SPD und
Grüne haben heute sehr gelassen betont
gelassen darauf reagiert was aber
vielleicht auch schon ein Hinweis darauf
ist dass beide da noch einige
Konfrontationen mit der FDP erwarten
dann vielen Dank für die Einordnung
Schalke Unterlagen nach Berlin
ja die politische Landkarte in Berlin
hat sich mit dieser Wahl deutlich
verändert zum Vergleich schauen wir mal
auf 2021 im Zentrum der Hauptstadt
holten die Grünen die meisten Stimmen im
Osten der City die Linkspartei und vor
allem in den Wohngebieten am Stadtrand
da gab es großflächige Hochburgen von
SPD und CDU ja nach der Wahl ist gestern
das Rot komplett verschwunden ist
dominiert jetzt das Schwarz der CDU das
Tief ihrer Sozialdemokraten bekommt auch
Franziska Giffey zu spüren Berlins
Regierende Bürgermeisterin verlor ihren
Wahlbezirk Neukölln über den Tag nach
der Wahl Markus groß
Kai Wegner der Überraschungssieger Wahl
mit 10% Punkten Vorsprung gewonnen doch
sein Erfolg ist noch kein echter Sieg
für den Wechsel im Roten Rathaus braucht
er Partner
wir haben ein ganz klaren Auftrag dass
wir eine Regierung bilden sollen und wir
haben ja heute auch eingeladen zu
Sondierungsgesprächen sowohl die SPD als
auch die Grünen und jetzt sind wir auf
die Reaktionen gespannt und ich hoffe
dass wir Ende der Woche Anfang nächster
Woche mit den Sondierungen beginnen
ewiges Warten auf Bürgeramt Termine die
Verwaltung ein Dauer Ärgernis die
silvesterkrawalle haben die Stimmung in
der Stadt aufgeheizt die CDU antwortete
darauf mit einer law and order Politik
und es gab eine Menge Unzufriedenheit
mit dem Berliner Senat auch mit der
regierenden Bürgermeisterin und es ist
kein Wegner und vor allem auch der CDU
gelungen diesen Protest in ihre Bahnen
zu lenken dagegen ist Franziska giffeis
SPD nicht angekommen Platz zwei denkbar
knapp vor den Grünen jetzt gelte es zu
sondieren mit der CDU und den bisherigen
Koalitionspartnern gestern noch
Führungsanspruch heute Moderatorin
wir sind Zweitplatzierte Partei und das
bedeutet dass wir schon auch sehen dass
die SPD weiter auch ein wichtiger und
bedeutender Teil dieser Landesregierung
sein wird die Grünen und ihre
Spitzenkandidatin jarasch in der
Bredouille erliegen sie den Avancen der
CDU oder gibt es ein weiter so wir haben
ja von Anfang an gesagt dass wir das
jetzige die jetzige Regierungskoalition
mit SPD und Linken gerne fortsetzen
wollen und das gilt auch weiterhin aber
wir werden sicher auch Gespräche mit der
CDU führen der Poker um die Macht im
Roten Rathaus hat begonnen Ausgang offen
der Poker hat begonnen zuständig bei uns
für die Berliner Landespolitik ist
Stefan Merseburger Stefan was führte zu
dieser komplizierten Ausgangslage und
das macht die Hauptstadt jetzt damit
naja das bringt Unruhe und Bewegung wir
haben es gehört SPD und Grüne werden mit
der CDU sein die sondieren gleichzeitig
hat Rot-Grün-Rot weiter eine stabile
parlamentarische Mehrheit giffeis SPD
hat eine desaströse schlappe erlebt das
bringt das führt dazu dass es rumort in
der Partei da gibt es Stimmen die sagen
giffe muss weg aber es gibt eben auch
die Stimmen die sagen sie soll bleiben
und weitermachen als wenn gleich
geschwächte Regierende Bürgermeisterin
da wird ihr die grüne Jahres nicht im
Weg stehen sie hat ihre Rot-Grün rote
Präferenz erneuert aber sie wird auch
Gespräche mit der CDU führen und da gibt
es starke inhaltliche Differenzen bei
den Themen Migration Verkehr innere
Sicherheit Bauen Wohnen die Berliner
Grünen sind ziemlich links und die
Berliner CDU steht ziemlich weit rechts
schwarz grün hätte in Berlin den Reiz
des Neuen doch dafür müssten beide
Seiten richtig Kröten schlucken danke
nach Berlin Stefan Merseburger
zwar fühlt sich die Bundes CDU vom
Berliner Ergebnis bestätigt und
beflügelt aber ein anderes Thema dürfte
den Christdemokraten schwer im Magen
liegen und das heißt Hans-Georg Maaßen
die CDU will den Ex
verfassungsschutzchef unter anderem
wegen völkischer Ausdrucksweisen aus der
Partei schmeißen und stellte dafür heute
die Weichen Diana zimmermann
der Parteivorsitzende mit leicht
gequältem Gesichtsausdruck er weiß der
CDU steht ein mühsames Verfahren bevor
der ehemalige Verfassungsschutzpräsident
Hans-Georg Maaßen so der Vorwurf der
Christdemokraten vertrete zunehmend
rechtsextreme Positionen und habe der
CDU nachhaltig geschadet Hans-Georg
Maaßen hat sich sowohl in der Wortwahl
als auch in seinen inhaltlichen Themen
ganz klar von Grundpositionen der CDU
entfernt hat in der CDU nichts mehr
verloren wenig überraschende juristmaßen
Wert alles abhält das Verfahren gegen
ihn für rechtswidrig verteidigt seine
Äußerungen etwa dass es in Deutschland
einen weit verbreiteten anti-deutschen
Rassismus gebe seine eigenen Partei
wirft Maßen Anti deutsche Ideologie vor
das Ausschlussverfahren so klagte in
einem 26-seitigen Brief an den
CDU-Generalsekretär sei eine Schmutz und
Rufmordkampagne deren Ziel darin
bestünde eine Brandmauer in der CDU
gegenüber all denen zu errichten die den
Links Grünen Fotos der Parteiführung
nicht mittragen wollen
auch Friedrich Merz spricht von einer
Brandmauer nach rechts
wir sind konservativ wir sind liberal
wir sind christlich-sozial aber wir sind
nicht rechtsradikal und wir nähern uns
auch nicht der AFD an an keiner Stelle
und deswegen hält die Brandmauer gerade
an dieser Stelle und das war notwendig
heute noch einmal klar zu stellen und zu
unterstreichen Thema in der CDU war
heute auch die von Maaßen geführte
werteunion eine Gruppierung die sich
selbst als rechtskonservativ definiert
und außerhalb der Partei steht Friedrich
Merz betonte eine Mitgliedschaft in der
CDU und in der werteunion sei
unvereinbar
Hans-Georg Martens Ausschlussverfahren
wird in erster Instanz vor dem
kreisspartei-gericht Thüringen
verhandelt die CDU rechnet mit massivem
Widerstand des einstigen
Verfassungsschutzes und einem sehr
langen Verfahren
genau vor einer Woche ereigneten sich
die schweren Erdbeben mit den zwischen
über 7 und 30 Todesopfern in der Türkei
und Syrien diverse internationale
Rettungsdienst haben jetzt die Abreise
angetreten weil die Chancen nach 7 Tagen
noch Überlebende zu finden immer
geringer werden nach wie vor fehlt es
vielen Menschen in der Erdbebenregion am
aller nötigsten Thomas Gonsior beginnt
seinen Bericht in der türkischen
provinzia
Schnee drückt auf die Trümmer die Dörfer
in den Bergen wie eingefroren mehr als
eine Woche nachdem die Erde bebte bleibt
Hilfe hier aus sie versuchen sich selbst
zu helfen Sie versuchen zu überleben
wir haben das Beben überstanden
hoffentlich überleben wir auch das jetzt
es ist kalt -10 - 15 Grad Zelte gibt's
nicht wir haben Kinder Enkel wo sollen
sie bleiben ich weiß es nicht
Verzweiflung Ratlosigkeit nehmen zu und
die Angst vor solchen denn überall
liegen tote Körper veränderte Tiere seit
Tagen neue Bilder vom vergangenen Montag
sie zeugen von der Naturgewalt die ganze
Landstriche einfach in Stücke Riss
dennoch dort wo Hilfskräfte hingegangen
retten sie immer noch leben hier eine
sechsjährige nach 178 Stunden jede
Rettung ein Triumph
solche Momente aber werden rar kaum
Hoffnung auf Überlebende deshalb sind
deutsche Ersthelfer abgereist spanische
auch sie beklagen das Behörden schwere
Maschinen einsetzen wo noch Überlebende
sein könnten das heißt Menschen werden
in Trümmern sterben so kann man nicht
handeln
von internationalen Rettungseinsätzen
sind große Teile Syriens überhaupt weit
entfernt Zerstörung Tod in der Region
iClip und
Protestaktionen gegen die Vereinten
Nationen die hatten zugegeben dass man
die Menschen dort im Stich ließ
mittlerweile aber kommt Hilfe untrucks
Rollen Richtung Nordwest Syrien auch in
der Türkei etwa in gölbersche werden
noch tausende Menschen vermisst mehr als
eine Woche ist vergangen und erschrecken
nimmt kein Ende
ich muss mich korrigieren ich meinte
natürlich über
37.000 Todesopfer nach der
Erdbebenkatastrophe inzwischen Britta
Jäger ist für uns im türkischen Adana
Britta eine Woche nach den Beben wie ist
die Situation im Katastrophengebiet
also wenn jetzt nach all diesen Tagen
immer noch Menschen lebend aus den
Trümmern geborgen werden dann sind das
Glücksmomente von denen die Betroffenen
hier unheimlich zehren aber die werden
eben immer und immer weniger und es
bleibt dann überwiegend nur noch Wut
Trauer und Angst dass Militär hat seine
Präsenz verschärft will Behinderung
verhindern aber es gibt eben noch viele
die Angst haben dass in all dem Leid
eben noch ihr letztes Hab und Gut
gestohlen wird auch ist die Befürchtung
groß dass die Schuldigen dieser
Katastrophe nicht zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden die Regierung hatte schon
viele Bauunternehmer die angeblich
gefuscht haben verhaftet aber eben nicht
die Mitarbeiter von Bau Bauämtern
beispielsweise weil die haben das ja
alles genehmigt und abgenommen in Hatay
statt hat er Gouverneur am Wochenende
eine lokales Amt abreißen lassen mit der
Begründung dass es einsturzgefährdet
gewesen sei und mit damit auch zerstört
ganz viele Unterlagen und Beweise und
viele in der sozusagen also dieses
Gebäude war absolut stabil das hätte
nicht abgerissen werden müssen und sie
vermuten eben dass das sozusagen die
Beweise vernichtet werden sollten die
Korruption nachweisen könnten und wenn
das der Fall sein sollte dann würde das
die ganze Lage natürlich noch viel viel
bitterer machen
Britta Jäger in Adana vielen Dank ab
19.30 Uhr schauen wir in einem
zdf-spezial ausführlich ins
Erdbebengebiet direkt nach unserer
Sendung die Betroffenen in der Türkei
und in Syrien die werden noch lange
Unterstützung brauchen so könnten sie
helfen über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die bahn.de
65-100
400-100 400 Stichwort ZDF rbb in Türkei
Syrien alles auch noch mal zum Nachlesen
auf
spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text
Seite 89.0 und sie können auch den
QR-Code scannen
seit heute bildet die Bundeswehr
ukrainische Soldaten am Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 aus das Training das findet
hauptsächlich im niedersächsischen
Munster statt und soll Ende März
abgeschlossen sein in diesem Zeitraum
sollen die Leopard Panzer auch an Kiew
übergeben werden heftige Gefechte in der
Ukraine gibt es weiterhin besonders rund
um bachmut die Stadt im Osten ist seit
Monaten umkämpft die ukrainische Seite
spricht von einer schwierigen Lage der
russische Beschuss sei massiv
jetzt schauen wir nach Israel wo sehr
viele Angst um die Demokratie haben
10.000 protestierten heute gegen die
Justizreform der Regierung Netanyahu sie
könnte dazu führen dass mit einfacher
Parlamentsmehrheit Entscheidungen des
höchsten Gerichts ausgehebelt werden
heute dazu eine erste wichtige und
extrem turbulente Abstimmung aus Israel
Michael Beverungen
Demokratie Demokratie skandieren sie
immer wieder sie sind aus dem ganzen
Land nach Jerusalem gekommen und aus
fast allen Gesellschaftsschichten an die
hunderttausend Menschen protestieren vor
dem Parlament der Knesset gegen die
religiösen nationalistische Regierung
die will den Obersten Gerichtshof
entmachten und die Besetzung der Richter
unter ihre Kontrolle bringen wie in
anderen autoritären Staaten
man muss die Minderheitenrechte schützen
und die Gewaltenteilung zwischen
Legislative und Judikative das Oberste
Gericht ist da um mich zu schützen ohne
es können wir als demokratischer Staat
nicht existieren na AMA arbeitet im
Hightech-Bereich alle Branchen und
Altersstufen sind hier vertreten dieser
Protest ist vielschichtig selten hat
sich in Israel ein so breites
bündnishaus so unterschiedlichen Teilen
der Gesellschaft für ein gemeinsames
politisches Ziel zusammengefunden doch
die die drinnen der knisse die
politische Macht haben halten an ihren
Ziel fest sie wollen unverändert die
politische Gewaltenteilung aushebeln
die Abgeordneten der Opposition im
Justizausschuss der Knesset manche
Weinen der Druck auf die Regierung die
bisher jeden Dialog abgelehnt hat steigt
die meisten Bürger Israels wollen keine
Anarchie sie wollen eine substanziellen
Dialog und
Wahrheit
vielleicht ein verklausuliertes
Gesprächsangebot vielleicht auch nicht
mit Anarchie hatte der friedliche
Protest heute jedenfalls nichts zu tun
[Musik]
am 13 februar 1945 und in den Tagen
danach legten die Alliierten Dresden in
Schutt und Asche bis zu 25.000 Menschen
starben bei den Luftangriffen heute hat
die Stadt an die Bombardierung im
Zweiten Weltkrieg erinnert um die
Dresdner Innenstadt schlossen sich
tausende zu einer Menschenkette zusammen
als Zeichen für Frieden viele zündeten
Kerzen an im Gedenken an die Opfer von
Krieg und Nationalsozialismus
bei uns geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
Sport und dem alljährlichen Super Bowl
Spektakel Sven ja der 57 Super Bowl war
nicht nur die erwartete Mega-Show
sondern auch ein spannendes
Footballspiel zwischen den Kansas City
Chiefs und den Philadelphia Eagles am
Ende waren es Quarterback Patrick
mahomes und seine Chiefs die jubeln
durften Patrick mahomes im Konfetti
freuten taumeln zum zweiten Mal in vier
Jahren gewinnt der Star Quarterback den
Superbowl mit seinen Kansas City Chiefs
das Spiel ein Kopf an Kopf rennen bis
kurz vor Schluss starke Aktionen auch
von Philadelphia squarterbacken hurts
beim Spielstand von 35 zu 35 dann der
große Moment von Kika Harrison sein
field Gold bringt den Schiff die
entscheidenden drei Punkte für den Sieg
knapp 70.000 Fans kamen ins Stadion um
einen Abend ganz im Sinne des Sports zu
feiern
wir die Nationalhymne singen spüren wir
dass wir immer noch ein Land sind und so
sollte es doch sein die Halbzeit wurde
zum großen Rihanna Comeback nach rund
sechs Jahren Auszeit von der Musik nach
der Show ließ sie noch die Überraschung
verkünden dass sie mit ihrem zweiten
Kind schwanger ist am Ende liegen sich
auch die beiden Kelz die Brüder die
gegeneinander antraten in den Armen so
bleibt der Superbowl in Erinnerung als
Abend der großen Geschichten an dem es
Amerika trotz aller gesellschaftlichen
Differenzen schaffte für einen Moment
zusammen zurück
Deutschlands Basketballerinnen sind
zurück auf der europäischen Bühne im
letzten em-quali-spiel gewannen sie
gegen Bosnien-Herzegowina mit 92 zu 61
und holten sich damit nach 12 Jahren
wieder das Ticket für die EM in Israel
im kommenden Sommer
um das Ticket fürs Viertelfinale der
Champions League kämpfen morgen die
Fußballer des FC Bayern im Hinspiel
gegen Paris St Germain bekommt es der
deutsche Rekordmeister nun wohl doch mit
den Pariser Weltstars zu tun
gute Stimmung im Abschlusstraining der
Bayern trotz hohen Drucks der auf der
Mannschaft von Julian nagelsmann lastet
nach dem Zähnen 3:0 gegen Bochum am
Wochenende fordert nicht nur der Trainer
eine Leistungssteigerung die Siegchancen
gegen Paris der Vorstand nicht ganz so
überzeugt ich würde sagen fifty-fifty
also das sind Wahnsinn Spieler drin
einer von diesen wahnsinnsspielern
Kilian mbappé wirkt nach
Muskelverletzung wieder topfit zusammen
mit dem zuletzt geschunden Messi im
Kader die Rückkehr der Superstars ein
echter Lichtblick für Paris verlorene
Heimspiele Pokal aus die Begegnung
morgen richtungsweisend für beide Teams
tja das war es vom Sport mich Tipp 1:1
mal gucken danke schön
der Spätwinter der kommt morgen meist
sonnig und recht mild daher Details hat
dazu gleich Katja horneffer
Marietta slomker ordnet die
Nachrichtenlage dann um 21:45 Uhr im
heute-journal ein gleich nach dem Wetter
dann das zdf-spezial zur
Erdbebenkatastrophe danke schön fürs
zuschauen und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend sehr groß waren heute die
wetterunterschiede je nachdem ob Sie im
Dauergrau hier an der Donau saßen ob
sich der Nebel bei ihnen auflöste wie
zum Beispiel hier am Rhein oder ob sie
unter dieser hochnebeldecke saßen die
allerdings von zwei Seiten
zusammengedrückt wurde vielleicht saßen
sie aber auch im Sonnenschein dann
konnten sie in Köln bis zu 16 Grad
erleben im Dauergrau an der Donau waren
es dagegen nur ein Grad heute Nacht
sinken die Wetter auf drei Grad hier im
Nordwesten und bis minus fünf Grad an
den Alpen das kann vereinzelt für
reifenglätte reichen wenn Nebel und
Dunst angefroren die hochnebeldecke hier
im Nordosten die hält sich zäh und das
bleibt auch morgen über Tag so die
meisten von uns haben aber nach Nebel
und Dunst wieder viel Sonnenschein
Vorsicht so steigen die Temperaturen
dann wenn es grau bleibt nur so auf 5
Grad aber mit Sonnenschein gibt's doch
deutlich zweistellige Temperatur und an
diesem Wetter ändert sich auch am
Mittwoch nichts am Donnerstag kommen
dann von Nordwesten Regenwolken an und
am Freitag Zeiten die sich weiter aus
und dann wird es sogar richtig stürmisch
bei Temperaturen von 6 bis 13 Grad ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend